we're gonna start with some questions
that we got from YouTube sure we have
one that came in from que puta and que
rights how were you able to juggle a
production company through high school
and university and still be a comedy
legend all those years Wow
that's all news to me oh um I mean when
I was a kid I started my first
production company who knows maybe nine
or ten boys destiny productions like it
was making movies making little videos
with my friends was my hobby like it's
what I did like when other kids were
playing soccer or kissing girls like I
was making little movies with my friends
and as I got older as I got in high
school I found fellow friends who wanted
to make movies and we formed a
production company even just to make we
made a feature in high school you know
we made three features by the time like
I went to college over the summers and
from a young age I knew that I wanted to
make movies and work in in creative
entertainment fields and and like I
couldn't imagine doing anything else
and so like starting my own company that
started as a goof and then actually I've
johnny voodoo Productions which I
started like as a goof in high school it
now is Mike my actual LLC production
company that I used to make stuff I just
maintained it ever since and and and
yeah I guess I've just always kept that
going because it's like I have jobs to
make money but then also for fun or as a
creative artistic outlet like there's
the stuff I do over here and luckily we
live in you know in an industry we're
working in industry where sometimes you
can even make those things overlap I
don't know if that answered your
question at all I think it's K as a
question but I think that does know you
talked about you grew up in I'm sorry I
just say it nollans not
it's New Orleans we don't like knowledge
when you spell it in awl IMS let's try
it in the hole Oh No see you back yeah
but so you were from born raised in New
Orleans on the bayou
not really the Bayou but yeah I grew up
right on the other side of the
Mississippi River like from the French
Quarter and yeah like growing up in New
Orleans was it really I didn't realize
how unique it was like while I was
growing up because I just thought every
city was like this so I go every city's
got it super old and you have Mardi Gras
right I didn't really I don't know I
just didn't understand its uniqueness
until later on when I left and I was
like oh that's a pretty cool place and
the whole city has a vibe of like
creative energy and and really
supporting you know creativity and and I
loved it and there's like a supernatural
sort of medium oh yeah ghosts
everything's haunted anywhere you go
there's some spirit and doing something
nice hopefully behaving hopefully you
should usually pretty good okay well
that's the holding of item Orleans is
like anywhere you go and be like hey see
that house over there it's like a
hundred eighty years old and bunch of
people died in that house okay cool but
now it's a dentist's office sure now it
does root canals okay so then we have
one here from Nate's film tutorials I
need how did you go about starting your
own production company and what advice
would you give to those who are starting
out so we kind of talked about that yeah
I mean all you gotta do to start a
production company is register with the
city and then you have a company but
then it's just like then you actually
have to go do stuff you know then you
have to make stuff and
you know like I live in Los Angeles no
matter where you live you find the
creative people in your city and you
just kind of like get to know them and
hang out with them and become friends
with them and it's amazing you know even
going to a barbecue like it's a friend's
birthday barbecue and you go and you
start talking to people like so what do
you do you're like oh I'm a composer oh
cool
like I actually have been looking for a
composer and then you get their card or
you get the information the next time
you need a composer you met that person
at a barbecue and you know that they
often say like in the movie business
it's who you know right but it that
doesn't just mean like your family
connections or something it's just like
who you know like socially in life you
know because you into a barbecue and you
met a composer and then part of like
having a production company or making
stuff is just knowing people in all
fields it's not just you know like as a
writer I sit at home in working in my
laptop by myself but like if you want to
actually produce stuff and have a
production company you need to know
people in all the fields you need to
know sound people you need to know
composers you need to know craft
services people like you have to just
get out and and like be introduced to
people in all fields so that when it
come times to make something if you have
a production company that makes stuff
you need to be able to call anyone in
any position and if someone's like hey
do you got you have a Transpo guy like
someone who drives trucks you're like
yeah I know three I know three people I
could call right now you know and that's
really helpful you have to force
yourself to get out sometimes oh yeah
yeah I like to be an isolationist
isolationist often but also like just
trying to get on set in any capacity
even you know when I was younger I was
just a PA on set and you just meet
everybody right you meet the craft
services person you meet the Transpo
guys you meet the hair and makeup people
and you become friendly with them and
you get to know them and then
you know so much of production is just
referrals of you know the DP is working
on a new project and that project needs
craft services and music oh I know a
person that I met on my last thing here
why don't you call them and so I mean I
love being unset like I love directing
and being on set and like it's so much
fun that to me that's that's almost like
networking right is just being on a set
and like meeting everybody because some
directors will go on a set and just not
talk to anybody but their ad or like the
actors you know but then but I'm someone
who like on the first day I try to
introduce myself to everybody I want to
know who the Transpo guys are like I
want to know every art department person
like what is their name and get to know
them all and become Facebook friends at
them and cuz maybe we'll work together
again maybe I'll need you or you'll need
me who knows
you